Speaker 1: All right.
Let's look at a few other things that happened
yesterday.
George Santos seemed to forget his own name
on the floor of the house multiple times.
His name was called for a vote on Speaker
of the House on the fifth ballot.
He seems not to recognize his own name, which
is just funny because, of course, his full
name is George Anthony Devil there Santos.
And it raises a question of whether does he
even really go by George Santos?
Normally, maybe he goes by Anthony Duvall
there or George Duvall there or Anthony Sanders.
I don't know.
But here he is.
They call him multiple times.
Doesn't seem to recognize they're calling
him for a vote.
The guy to his right seems to tell him like,
hey, that's your name, sir.
Speaker 4: Santos.
Santos.
Speaker 1: SARBANES okay.
And they move on to Sarbanes, and then he
holds up his hand and yells out that he's
voting for McCarthy.
Speaker 2: Jeffries You even.
Speaker 1: You even see Matt Gates come by.
Just kind of like, what is it that is even
going on here?
So just kind of weird.
Everything about Santos is strange.
For all we know, he's used to being called
some other name.
I don't know.
And it seems that he is continuing to struggle
to sort of build community in the House of
Representatives.
And I don't really know the end game for Santos.
The first 48 hours are not sustainable.
Running away with a huge backpack, running
away from reporters who want to ask him questions.
Sitting by himself in the floor of the house,
picking his nose, not recognizing his own
name.
And it's all just truly bizarre.
But I also have kind of like a morbid curiosity
where, like, how how awkward can this possibly
get?
And you all know, I love awkward.
So we're going ahead and going to go ahead
and follow that.
And by the way, the lies from Jorge Santos
haven't stopped since he arrived in Washington,
D.C.
Let's talk about that next.
Jorge Santos lied about being sworn in on
Tuesday.
I don't know how else to explain this to you.
Jorge Santos was not sworn in on Tuesday.
Nobody was.
But he put out a press release saying he was
sworn in.
It's very binary.
It's not a matter of opinion.
It's not a technicality.
He was not sworn in on Tuesday, but he posted
a press release saying that he indeed was
the Office of Jorge Santos Publishing on Tuesday
press release swearing in as member of the
118th Congress.
U.S. Representative Jorge Santos was sworn
in as a member of the United States House
of Representatives by the Speaker of the House
on January 3rd, 2023.
Hilariously, not only is that not true, there
was no speaker there.
They're voting on a speaker.
The whole problem is there's no speaker.
And he's like, Oh yeah, the speaker swore
I was sworn in by the speaker on Tuesday.
Now, it didn't happen.
If you now go and look at Santos's website,
this press release has been deleted.
It's now says Access Denied.
You were not authorized to access this page
because it's not true.
They had to remove it.
Swearing in, of course, happens after the
speaker has been elected, after the speaker
has been elected.
So my question to you about this is the following
Does Santos know that he wasn't sworn in and
this was published as a lie because he must
have staff.
You would think if he goes to his staff and
says, Hey, please publish that I was sworn
in, you'd think someone would say, Oh, you
weren't sworn in, you haven't been sworn in.
That happens after the speaker is elected.
So I don't really understand how this ends
up being the thing that happens.
It's very, very strange.
Tell me what you think.
Was it a lie?
Was he confused?
Whatever.